you must be new security guards can I uh
help you officer have you met them
yet met
who them Emma congrats on the film oh
thank you Jordan Peele has one of my
favorite quotes when it comes to like
the horror genre he says the difference
between the only difference between
horror and comedy is music and I felt
like you injected a lot of humor into
this movie and I always wanted to ask
you how do you decide how much humor to
put into a film like this so that you're
not tipping the scale yeah I mean Jordan
P's a master of that combination and
I've heard him talk too about how the
timing of comedy and horror are so
similar which of course is totally true
like Landing a joke and Landing a scare
are really precise in terms of timing um
but in terms of the combination I think
it's like project dependent completely
and with this one we knew like the world
of Freddy's was so much fun and that
with without having some levity and
humor in it we'd be missing an
opportunity to you know bring it to life
in a fully dimensional way yeah well you
totally brought it to life and there's
something innately humorous just about
animatronics in general yes and I think
when the world thinks of animatronics if
you're if you're not a fan of Five
Nights at Freddy's you're thinking
Chuck-E-Cheeses and I read that you were
totally fascinated by them I was scared
by the animatronics at chuckecheese is I
think it was like their big eyes and the
delay and blinking but I wanted to ask
you Emma what do you think is so
unintentionally creepy about
animatronics oo you know it's it's I
think it lies in the space between them
being alive and not not alive we are
kind of controlling them whether they've
been programmed or in our case we had uh
puppeteers you know doing all of the
animations offscreen um but every now
and then they'll do something on their
own and or like an imperfection will
just pop up and they've got a
personality all to themselves and I
think it's that that like soul for lack
of a better word that they end up
inhabiting that is so eerie and amazing
and wild and at times friendly you know
it's it's all the things and you're
always on your toes because you don't
know what side of it you're going to get
yeah I don't want to give anything away
but the story you put behind the souls I
thought was so good excited for the
world to discover that you said
puppeteering off like tell me more about
that that sounds really interesting it
was fascinating the animatronics were
built by Jim Henson's Creature Shop
right uh who have an incredible history
of building amazing puppets and in our
case these full size
animatronics um so yeah there were I
think foxy at
full movement capacity took like six
puppeteers to operate so we were
we were you know using a lot of really
really talented people to make these
characters come to life and the most um
nuanced and detailed of ways it's so
cool I've been to Jim Henson's like this
a lot and they put on these adult shows
and it really is crazy to see these
people are like the most talented people
in the world they really are pu it up
shows yeah the yeah you've been they're
so funny I was reading too that you
actually got to go to the Creature Shop
as they were making them oh yeah and I
was wondering is there one day that you
went there that just like stood out to
you or out of you know Freddy foxy at
Bonnie and Chica was there one that took
longer or was harder to just get right
well they were all kind of uh following
a similar schedule of like design phase
prep phase build phase so they were all
kind of coming to life together um each
one posed different challenges in terms
of of the specifics that we needed to
get right but I would say the first time
I went blew my mind because there's
amazing puppets all over their Creature
Shop from other movies and and TV shows
that I had grown up on and you know dark
crystals over here and Muppets are over
there and it's you know just incredible
but then every time I went to check in
on the process a new part of the design
or build phase was happening so it was
all exciting to me I would say the
biggest standout moment was when we came
for the final show and tell and we got
these animatronics on their feet for the
first time and that was a real mind
explosion moment for sure I feel like
that's what going to happen to fans of
the video game when they watch this
movie because you guys really took the
time to like get it right I wanted to
ask you when it speaking of the video
game what parts of gameplay like what
elements of the gameplay were you so
excited to include in the film and how
did you incorporate it yeah I mean just
for me personally I was so taken with
how the game made me feel like I was
just always so tense and tuned into the
atmospheric elements of the game the
sound design and the things you can't
see but you know that are lurking so as
a genre filmmaker that was just like
such ripe uh inspiration for bringing it
to the cinema but in terms
of the actual game play you know we were
working alongside Scott cofin who has
built this whole franchise and universe
and getting the elements of the lore
really right and accurate and the
balance of how much we were including
versus new story elements that we were
introducing just specific to this movie
were you know really uh just needing the
the guidance of of the Creator so that
we knew the fans would really you know
click with it yeah um and that it would
be what they want hope expect and
hopefully so much more I think they're
going to love that you know the
monitoring of the animatronics through
the security cameras and turning the
lights on and off like I thought it was
really cool included all that stuff yeah
and it really like came to life
obviously when Matthew Lillard who I
just adore um you know has a presence in
this movie obviously um a big presence a
big presence I heard him say that he
signed on to a three picture deal and I
was wondering where would you like to
see the sequels go and would you be
interested in directing them oh yeah I
would absolutely be very interested in
continuing you know building stories in
this world Building stories with these
characters that I now feel really um not
just in love with but invested in and um
you know would love to see where they go
uh I think in terms of the franchise if
we were lucky enough to be able to
continue making more films we would just
really be excited to incorporate more
elements of the lore that you know
relate to game two game three and and
then also as I said just continuing
these characters on a journey that feels
uniquely their own um that has come out
of just the world of the movie nice can
you tell us anything you know
about you'll have to tune in to
see